So, as we thought about
creating the purchasing flow,
what we wanted to do was we wanted to
create an experience that was familiar.
But, what really made it
super optimized is for
if you had a product out there
to make people purchase it.
And for us,
it is really important.to make it
like a clean purchase experience.
And so, as we thought about how we
wanted to make our purchase flow
uniquely Teespring, one of the things
which we did realize was that
Teespring content is very much targeted.
Or is very much optimize for
people wanting to show
it to their friends and share it like on
all the different platforms out there.
And so one of our thoughts
was how can we make this
an experience where kind of people are
actually purchasing from the page but
at the same time encourage them to
share it via email, Facebook, Twitter,
Pinterest and all these other channels.
And so that was kind of the only other
kind of special optimization layer,
I'd say,
that we did on the purchase flow.
But otherwise,
the purchase flow kind of is a very
[INAUDIBLE] understood thing
across most e-commerce companies.